so have you had time to make your place
are you into like design and stuff like
you know like interior design with your
new place I love it it's my passion I
like to keep the do you love interior I
love it it's like to me it's nesting
nesting it's the most relaxing thing to
be able to make your space I mean just
your dressing rooms here are iconic oh
my gosh and then I went I could live in
that's my art Department they're so
great well they're amazing but I try to
be my own art department and so I have
in the so I've painted every wall I've
muraled I've you know made you guys are
going to get a little sense gotten lots
of stuff from vintage you're my sister
she's creative like that she like does
it herself as well she does those are my
furry stools
zamaki who makes those and people walk
into the kitchen and they scream because
they think I have like three sort of
random animals whose hairs whose hairs
have been dyed with Manic Panic but no
those are my stools do you have animals
because do they attack that we do have
it we have two cats and two dogs and the
funny thing is our dogs are hairless
so our stools have hair but our dogs
don't
your husband does so much already thank
you so much and I love doing it and for
a while my husband was just like yes you
do you it's but then I think I've
empowered him a little bit too much and
now well he's creative he's in the music
world yeah he is he's there he is I miss
him so now he likes to be a part of it
too now what are their battles of like
oh no yes like now he's having opinions
and we can't have men having those
he's like so I live here too yeah and I
was like that's not what I signed up for
I signed up for completion you are
changing that's exactly right
[Music]
[Applause]